I've decided my new style is college
student on a Sunday night
kula make choices hey guys this Thursday
here on it's grace and that means tipsy
Thursday where I teach you tips on how
to do something I wrote on my tumblr
blog and I asked you what did you wanna
learn how to do today and someone said
turn creative ways tell the boss I hate
I'm quitting let's do it
I clearly look like someone that quit
their job weeks ago so here are 10 maybe
more creative ways to tell the boss that
you hate that you are quitting some of
these require cash but you can die with
that money in your pockets what better
way to get back at the boss you hate
than to spend too much money on an
elaborate quitting scenario okay we're
gonna start off really light here number
1 take a [ __ ] in your boss's desk and
then when they discover it walk into
their office and say and you thought I
never gave a [ __ ] at work I quit send
your boss an edible arena with a note
that says I quit eat me cuz it's edible
you can also buy edible panties if
they're cheaper because sometimes edible
arrangements are very expensive and then
the fruits just there you're like ah
what do I do with all these kebab sticks
now fill your boss's desk with a bunch
of dildos and then leave a note on the
desk that says you're kind of a dick I'm
quitting because a dildo is kind of a
dick like a dicks fraternal twin
that died and you mummified it and you
just kept it around
that's stuff functional walk into your
boss's office and say oh bus there was a
memo for you but I forgot where I put it
and then show me a Xerox of your butt
and if you don't want to Xerox Iran but
that's okay you probably have that crazy
intern that's so wild and fun and has
something to prove because they're
invincible because they're so young but
they're of legal age and it's okay to
ask them to Xerox their butt for you or
just Google Image Search a butt and
print it out I've done this go on
Craigslist and hire a really dirty gross
male stripper done then go into your
boss's office and say dear boss I am
very sorry I just don't feel that I have
growth in this environment anymore and
so I have to quit however I found a
replacement they certainly have growth
in this office hit it Ted and then you
let that male stripper do its thing and
then you smoke bomb and get yourself out
of there it's another Craigslist idea if
your boss is a man go on Craigslist hire
child actor to come in one day wander
into your boss's office and tell your
boss that they are their real father
once adequate time to respond has
happened walk in and say ha ha this is a
child actor I'm quitting isn't that a
relief compared to this in the adverse
sense if your boss is a female hire a
very very old desperate male actor to
wander into her office and say that they
are their actual father same thing
give it time walk and say whoa psych I
quit ha ha in relation to this possible
reality this is fine you suck
this may be complicated but somehow
a music playing device with a remote
control in the ceiling of your office
somewhere and then go into your boss's
office and quit and when you finally
quit hit the button and let your
computer play a kid rocks ball with the
bomb on repeat so your boss can never
find where the music is coming from
imagine this
for eight work hours tell your boss
you're going on your lunch break and
then go find the nearest pizza delivery
place order 50 pizzas to your office but
make sure that you pay extra so that the
delivery boy girl whoever it is when
they get to the office and the boss
informs them that heat in order the
pizzas they stay in that office and just
sob openly and wildly flailing it's
extra tip and then just never go back to
there hire kids from the local college
to come and play your camera crew and
forcefully walk into your boss's office
and say surprise this is Undercover Boss
I am the child of the owner of this
entire company and you've been acting
like a real dick [ __ ] and you know what
you're fired
then smoke bomb and get you all out of
there even the slow boom operator I have
to give this extra note that I do
encourage you quitting in an adult
respectable fashion even if your boss
sucks trust that you don't have to be
the one to make their life [ __ ] unless
like one of these ideas really appeals
to you
I can't stop you I can just say I do not
think that you should do this in your
life I don't know okay here's an extra
bonus idea that is not my idea do not
take credit for this but I learned about
this when I was a senior in high school
we were trying to figure out what kind
of senior prank we should pull on our
school and I think this could work for
quitting your job as well you need three
animals three of the same animals goats
are the best like guinea pigs mice pigs
all appropriate and you need to put some
sort of shirt or ribbon or sash on each
animal and on one animal put number one
on another animal put number two and on
another animal put number four and then
you let them loose in the office you say
you quit it's like a zoo in here you get
out and then your boss finds an animal
labeled number one number two and number
four where's number three